when you picture a superhero who do you
see Batman Superman spider-man the Hulk
thanks to a growing collection of data
we know that our cultural icons are not
consistent with what we look like as a
country this fact extends to virtually
every form of mass media in the States
our best data suggests that the American
population is roughly equal in gender
and about 38% our minority of some sort
which reveals a simple truth about the
latest Marvel superhero film people are
excited about Black Panther because the
demand for media that centers minorities
is far greater than the available supply
this becomes obvious when you look at a
series of studies by UCLA's school of
sociology
what we knew about diversity though so
we decided to design a report that would
be the gold standard in terms of looking
at the bird's-eye view of what's
happening and tracking that all the time
roughly one out of every ten major films
are directed by minorities a similar
percentage caste minorities in their
lead roles and even fewer of these films
are written by minorities this principle
applies to nearly every facet of media
including executives and talent agents
you can't underestimate the role of the
gatekeepers if you're not on the roster
you can have a hard time breaking in
which of course has created obstacles
for people of color and women in
particular which means that the culture
represented on screen is determined by a
sample that doesn't accurately represent
the population if you look at pop
culture depictions of Africa you don't
ever get to see like this place that's
supposed to be like the future well
condos kind of like this almost like
rewriting of history of life what life
would have been like is this amazing
fantasy that you never get to see on
screen Black Panther is all about
representation it centers the story on
women and people of color and the
representation matters to young people
and they're the future target audio
the minority share of the population was
relatively low in 1970 but today nearly
40% of the u.s. population is in a
minority group and that percentage is
only expected to increase the genre
doesn't matter audiences want to see
people like themselves on the screen and
if you have a good story and you know
that the narrative is compelling and you
have people of color in it then the
versed audiences are probably going to
go and see it
you